So how much energy has to be
given to food to heat it up?
If you want to heat up an
egg by 10 degrees Celsius,
how many joules does it take to do that?
So the answer to this, it
turns out, is contained
in a simple mathematical equation.
A little later on, I'm
going to try to convince you
that if you know how to use it
properly, you have the opportunity
to cook a perfect egg without investing
in a rather expensive immersion heater.
That is, by understanding the
equations that we give you,
you really will have the opportunity
to use them to invent new recipes,
if you so desire.
Now having said that as introduction,
let me go into the equation.
The equation says that Q equals mcp
delta T. So Q is the amount of heat
that you've dumped into the food.
And that is a quantity
that is measured in joules.
m is the mass of the food.
For the purposes of this equation,
m should be measured in kilograms.
So delta T is the
temperature difference.
That's the final temperature of the
food minus the initial temperature
of the food.
And it should be measured in either
degrees Celsius or degree Kelvin.
And finally, cp is a number that we
call the specific heat of a material.
It is the number that characterizes
how much something heats up when
you apply a specific amount of heat.
And it is measured in the units of
joules per kilogram per degree Celsius,
or degree Kelvin.
And this is a number
that we will give you,
and that actually is
different for different foods.
So it turns out that the
specific heat for water
is 4.18 joules per gram degree Kelvin.
That's the specific heat for water.
Now water is an important cooking
material, and we will talk about it.
So for eggs, another
important cooking material,
their specific heat is about 3.18
joules per gram per degree Kelvin.
For milk, it's about 3.85.
It's closer to water.
For beef, depending on the cut of beef,
it's somewhere between 2 and 1/2 and 3
and 1/2 joules per gram degree Kelvin.
For air, the specific heat of air is 1.
The specific heat of
olive oil, something
which is also useful for
cooking, is about 1.97 joules
per gram per degree Kelvin.
So it's actually a lower specific
heat by about a factor of 2,
than that of water.
Now actually those two
numbers, if you think
about them, the specific heat
of water and the specific heat
of olive oil, the fact that most
foods are between those two numbers
is not an accident by any means.
In fact, the main ingredient
of all food is water.
This is something that we're going
to have to think about constantly
throughout this course.
It will come up again and again
in one context or another.
And another important
ingredient to food of course,
is fat, which olive oil is a fat.
And fats tend to have a
specific heat around 2.
And foods like beef, it's
somewhere between 2 to 4.
And that's essentially why.
It's a little more
complicated than that.
But that's not a bad
explanation to get us started.
Now so to get us started,
let's actually do something.
So I want to calculate the energy that
it takes to boil one cup of water.
So it turns out that one
cup of water is 237 grams.
And so what I want to do is start
with water that's at room temperature.
So the temperature in this room
is about 23 degrees Celsius.
And I'd like to heat it to the boiling
point, which is 100 degrees Celsius.
And I'd like to know how much
energy do I have to dump in.
And when you multiply this out, it
turns out that the number that you get
is 76,280 joules.
So that's how much energy it takes to
boil a cup of water, 76,280 joules.
Now it's a little bit hard to
know how to think about that,
because it's just a number in joules.
So one way to think
about it, how much wood
would it take to make this much energy?
Now if you take the energy
density of wood, which I already
told you is 14 megajoules
per kilogram, then you
can calculate for yourself that
the amount of wood that it takes
is 76,280 joules divided by
14 megajoules per kilogram.
We find that it takes 5.4 grams of wood,
in order to create this much energy.